la radio elle est là et en fait sur le
kst tu as un fil que tu branches hissé
ce mercredi matin à la préfecture de
versailles l'agente ann motards dans la
police nationale sur le département
depuis deux ans joue les professeurs
lors de sa première rencontre de la
sécurité en tant qu'animateur le gardien
de la paix présente ses missions et
surtout son deux roues devant un public
assidu
j'avais les mêmes questions ça soit de
questions d'ordre général sur la police
est spécifiquement sur les sur les motos
si ça suscite des vocations
pourquoi pas que ce soit les garçons les
filles au revoir la réaction de la
centaine de collégiens et de lycéens
présents ce jour là il se pourrait que
certains en fils dans les prochaines
années l'uniforme bon vous savoir un peu
les coulisses du métier de gendarme
parce qu'on les voit beaucoup mais pas
hors travail quoi je trouve ça un peu un
peu quand même intéressant parce que
c'est quand même eux qui assurent notre
sécurité surtout qu'on a envie j'y
pirates en parallèle de cet atelier moto
les enfants ont pu découvrir une dizaine
de stands sur les pompiers la
gendarmerie encore la police criminelle
les démonstrations d'une quinzaine de
minutes avec des chiens renifleurs de
drogue étaient également au programme et
il est en train de chercher des
stupéfiants l'appareil a trouvé ça
passionnant sa mâchoire ça fait un peu
de la pub pour la police est ce que ça
ne prouve que faut pas cacher de la
drogue parce que il ya des personnes
enfin la police peut retrouver après la
drogue
nos drogues qui est caché pour les
étudiants la matinée s'est terminée par
une démonstration des techniques de la
brigade équestre hesdinoise pendant les
matchs où les manifestations
les rencontres de la sécurité se
poursuivent dans toute la france jusqu'à
ce samedi 14 octobre
chaque année deux cent mille personnes
participent à cet événement